-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy-, Golden Globe-,
and Academy Award-winning
actress you know from films
such as "Still Alice,"
"Far From Heaven,"
and "Crazy Stupid Love."
She's currently starring
in "Bel Canto,"
which is in select theaters
this Friday
and will be available
on digital and On Demand.
Let's take a look.
♪♪♪♪
-[ Singing in foreign language ]
-Please welcome to the show
Julianne Moore.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
Welcome.
-Thank you for having me.
-I am thrilled to have you here.
This is
one of my favorite books.
I love "Bel Canto."
It's a beautiful book.
-A beautiful, beautiful book.
-And you're playing --
anyone could have guessed --
an opera singer.
-I am, of course.
Yes, that's right.
-Of everything you've taken on,
that must have been
a very difficult task.
-Oh, it's so hard.
I can't sing.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-That was
Renée Fleming's voice.
That wasn't mine.
But, you know,
in order to do that,
you have to try
to learn to sing,
so I studied with her coach,
and I watched a lot of opera,
and I went to The Met,
and I did all this
other stuff
to learn about opera.
-Well, I was --
Because in that scene,
you know,
it really pushes in on you,
and when I was watching it,
I was like, "Oh, you have to --"
You can't just open your mouth
and move it.
You have to make
your whole body --
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-It's not just lip-sync video.
-And that was particularly bad
because it was outside.
So I would ask them to crank
it up as loud as possible
so that people wouldn't hear me.
But because it was outside,
we couldn't control the sound.
-So you were --
Were you singing at full volume?
I guess you have to.
-Yeah, it was pretty
humiliating.
[ Laughter ]
-Was there ever a situation
where people would say,
"Hey, you know what?
You're not that bad."
-Paul Weitz, the director,
would say that to me.
But I think he's --
-He's very nice.
I know Paul.
He's very nice.
-Really nice guy.
But you realize everybody in the
sound department can hear you
because you're mic'd, so they're
the ones who are there,
holding the boom, going...
[ Laughter ]
-You know, for those
who don't know the book,
it's this really, uh,
sort of a --
you wouldn't guess
from the title
and the fact
that you're an opera --
it's this thrilling story
about this hostage situation.
-It's based on a true story,
the 1996 hostage situation
in Peru at the Japanese embassy.
There wasn't
an opera singer there,
so that's invented,
but it really is --
It's a political thriller
and a love story.
-And one of the other
wonderful things,
because of
the actual real story,
it's also this wonderful
multiethnic cast.
Because it was all these people
trapped in an embassy who --
You know, there's --
You know,
translator plays a huge role
because people
can't communicate.
-And everybody spoke
their own language,
so there's Japanese
and English and Spanish
and French
and German and Polish.
And there was an actress --
actually,
a Guatemalan actress --
who just learned Spanish.
So she still
spoke Guatemalan sometimes,
and it was
an indigenous language.
It was amazing.
And nothing --
you know, and Ken Watanabe
plays my, I guess, boyfriend?
-Yeah, I'm gonna
sign off on boyfriend.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And he only
speaks Japanese to me,
and I only speak English to him.
So there are times
when we just don't --
we just communicate, you know,
in, like,
boyfriend/girlfriend language.
[ Laughter ]
-You know, it was what made it
such a beautiful book.
And, yes, a romantic thriller,
well-executed both on the page
and in the film,
which is really nice.
-Nice.
-You are -- just finished a film
in Upstate New York with your --
that your husband directed?
-Long Island.
Oyster bay, actually.
In Manhattan and in India.
We were -- and, yeah.
All those places.
-And you had visitors --
When you're working on a movie
set, sometimes visitors stop by.
They want to see
the magic of a film set.
-Well, yeah, and, you know,
Oyster Bay may not
seem like the country.
But it is deep, deep country,
with lots and lots of,
you know,
different kinds of wildlife.
-And this was --
This is an actual video you took
of the --
This would be craft service?
-This is late at night
at catering,
after things
are being cleared up.
-Okay, gotcha.
Let's see the help you got
on the cleanup.
[ Laughter ]
-There they are, yeah.
If you go --
They dip in afterward.
You see them going, like...
[ Laughter ]
"Wait a minute, wait a minute,
one more thing down there."
-Yeah. They're like,
"Look, we understand
this is a closed set.
We will be out of here
in a second."
-Exactly.
[ Laughter ]
-We're both gonna grab
one more --
we're gonna grab
two more things.
-That's right.
That's right, yeah.
-You have had some interactions
with the wildlife recently.
This was not your only one.
-Yes, we had a really, really
exciting thing happen.
I mean, not just the raccoons,
but we had a turtle birth
in our pool this summer.
-Okay, so, now,
is that something
you only find out once
the turtles are there?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Okay, so you don't see a
pregnant turtle walking around.
-No, no, no.
Nothing like that.
But they just --
they literally appear.
So what happens is,
turtles crawl up,
they crawl into your yard and
they lay their eggs somewhere.
And then,
when the babies are hatched,
they crawl toward
the nearest water source,
because they think
that's their environment,
and it just happened
to be our pool.
-Okay, gotcha.
-[ Laughs ]
-So, it's interesting
because if you'd have told me
how many turtles
are born at once...
-You wouldn't know, yeah.
-I wouldn't know.
That was over what I thought.
[ Audience "Ohhs" ]
-That's a lot of turtles, right?
-That's a lot of turtles.
-But that's nothing like,
you know,
delivering your own child
in a lobby.
-Right.
-So I'm saying this turtle birth
is nothing
to what you experienced.
-No, that's right.
My wife had a baby in a lobby.
-That's right, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And I think, like,
I would just say that
that mom turtle did nothing
compared to what she did.
-No, nothing compared
to what she did.
-Like, that's beautiful grass.
-Yes, exactly.
-Yeah.
We were nowhere near your pool.
-No!
[ Laughter ]
If she'd only had
a water source.
-Exactly.
-That's right, you wouldn't
have been in the lobby.
-As she was like --
She's like, "The baby's coming.
Get me
to Julianne Moore's pool."
I'm like, "We're too far away.
We're too far away."
-Not gonna make it.
-"I don't know where it is!"
Uh, this is very exciting to me,
as well.
'Cause, obviously,
our kids are young.
They cannot be involved
in our professional life yet,
but your daughter
worked on set for the film.
-Yeah, she did.
She was a P.A.
and an official --
-It was very nice to see
that you did not --
This was not some situation
where she was elevated
due to the fact
that her father was directing
and her mother was in the film.
-No, she's gonna work, man.
-She was working.
-She's gonna work.
-This is her job right there.
That is real work, right there.
-That's what she's gonna do.
[ Laughter ]
-Fully...
Fully holding an umbrella.
-Yeah. I was hot.
-Yeah.
-I was super, super hot,
so somebody's gonna do it.
-Yeah.
And I would imagine that would
literally be the only way
you could get your daughter
to hold an umbrella over you.
[ Laughter ]
Is to hire her.
-She's 16.
She's not gonna do that.
But, you know, she had
a headset and stuff, too,
and so she took her job
very seriously.
She'd be like, "Yeah,
no, I have eyes on Julie.
No, she's right here."
[ Laughter ]
"I got her. No.
Oh, no, no, no. She's 10-1,"
which means that
I'm going to the bathroom.
I'm like, "You don't have
to tell them everything!"
[ Laughter ]
She's like, "No, I do.
That's my job, Mom."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-Well, it's so lovely
that it's a family affair.
All you guys
and then a hundred turtles.
-Exactly. Just us.
-Just us.
-Yeah.